hello welcome to this video playing
Peregrine 64 from the UK and I had a
good game in the exchange way and as I
just tried again ok it seems to be in
fashion yeah Bishop h5 is a funny line
but i probably will duck this challenge
and play something and be quiet down
what did i do in the last game should be
three i guess all night deadly 92 right
and remember ok goes into this end game
so right over here i guess i don't know
that line at all that night at that hole
Bishop g4 line I don't know one of the
few lines in the way that i have never
checked
Wow ok if you tekes I understand each
for will hang
hmm just got maybe 96 okay interesting
interesting
he's got I mean he's moved all those
bones isn't this is also somewhat weak I
don't know
yeah so what now I take with the F ponen
my F porn might get into trouble
probably have to do that and then d
takes you for don't see how it keeps the
Jeep on and yeah that's possible Sherpa
I wonder I can also take and go g5 Wow
many many strange endgames possible here
okay I'll just recapture him but maybe
not promising much i wasn't sure if i
spend any longer it doesn't matter at
the end i lose to some stupid stuff for
time
sure I can take you five no way to check
oops cannot take you five
check yeah my structures not existing is
non-existent I have no structure and but
f-for maybe FYI it's got 93 a fortune
keep the night protected maybe I could
have gone tonight h 6 cm
check oh oh my god yeah I find ways to
lose every game man it's possible oh
yeah you just have a probably winning
endgame here and a blunder rook Wow
great and that provide was not winning
but it's just an extra porn or nothing
so you have good winning chances check
and I can just take the f 1 p-5 rook c
6-r those are the kind of things I have
to play for well okay if you cannot move
the beep on at least if I get it some
sort of slide hope them check
schedule f6 some problem now I need to
keep the f & horn
I only continue because the porn count
is so low there is only check one pawn
left now for him and this this is not
not so super trivial
time warning
yeah it's not so easy I mean probably
there is some way but then it gets to be
gets to be difficult so what difficult
now check it takes it i already have it
raw oh that's the best bad that's bad
news
mmm some chances to get that pawn I
definitely have some chances so we would
be comfortable with a drawl now I guess
yeah okay haha yeah it's we're very
lucky I just done it blunder the whole
whole piece that it's Jackie like
analyzing this yeah just just an old
move King be three or anything I'm just
that porn up and it's not so easy if I
haven't to get something on the King on
the queenside him his four against three
is not worth much and I can yeah I just
move those pawns forward so yeah it's
very good for white chat here I'm just
losing and we can maybe check how black
could affirm hope black could have won
this easier sadly I think this was okay
i'm not quite sure if you have to go to
you six I mean it can probably does win
anyway but now II don't really have to
check I mean this is winning it just the
way it went somehow got lucky and
irritated him so much that I thought he
had trouble keeping the sea porn just a
pretty pretty bad game overall okay
thanks for watching